انتقد سلامنا لكم TEDx ،
كيف حال الجميع شكرًا لكم ،
لذا أود أن أتوقف لحظة
لأقدم لكم نفسي اسمي حلوى القطيفة
كما ترون هناك أه أنا
لغوي أنا من محبي القطط.
أنا شاعر وأنا أعاني من اكتئاب مزمن وأنا
هنا للحديث عنه اليوم وأنا أعلم أنه
ليس الموضوع الأكثر متعة للحديث عنه
ولكني أشعر أنه يحتاج حقًا إلى
تسليط المزيد من الضوء عليه
خاصة في مجتمعنا في ثقافتنا
بالنسبة لنا لفترة طويلة ، فإن بلائي أو
شريك حياتي
إذا كان الاكتئاب يشكل
عائقًا في حياتي ، أعني يا إلهي
يمكنني التحدث كثيرًا عن الاكتئاب ولكن
لدي 15 دقيقة فقط لذلك
سأعطيك  تفاصيل شديدة عن ذلك ، لقد كنت
أعاني من الاكتئاب منذ قبل
أن أعرف حتى ما هو الاكتئاب ، لم أكن
أعرف حتى أنه كان هناك كلمة واحدة له حتى
وقت قريب ، لكن طوال الكثير من حياتي
كنت غارقًا في مشاعر اليأس
من اليأس  من عدم كفاية
مجرد عدم كونني جيدًا بما يكفي لقد أنفقت
الكثير من أموالي  لقد أثقل
شعوري بتقدير الذات وعدم معرفتي
أو عدم قدرتي على إخبار نفسي بأنني
كنت جيدًا بما يكفي لأي شيء ، لقد كان
وقتًا سيئًا حقًا في حياتي
واستمر لمدة عشر سنوات.
بالنسبة لي ، أعتقد أن قاعتي كانت
قبل عامين ، كنت طالبًا في
جامعة برينستون هنا في الرياض ،
وعندما دخلت الكلية لأول مرة كنت مثل
نجم الرماية ، كنت رائعًا ،
حسنًا ، حسنًا ، لست متألقًا ، لكنني كنت
جيدًا حقًا.  حصلت على 3.7 معدل تراكمي ،
كنت قائد فريق المناظرة كنت
رئيسًا لنادي الدراما ، ثم
بدأ اكتئابي في اللحاق بي
عندما يكون هناك شيء جديد ومثير ، فمن
الأسهل أن تكون متحمسًا بشأنه ولكن عندما
تسقط الأمور في الروتين  من
السهل جدًا على صديقك القديم
أن يعود ويبدأ في
افتراس مخاوفك ، وهكذا
ذهب أدائي الأكاديمي وانتقلت من كونك
طالبًا لامعًا زائدًا إلى
شخص كان تحت المراقبة الأكاديمية
مرات عديدة  لا أعرف حتى كم كان
الأمر كما لو أنك عدت إلى
الاختبار الأكاديمي مرة أخرى ، فلا بأس
أن يكون هذا هو الحضيض وكان ذلك
عندما بدأت أدرك أن لدي
مشكلة حقيقية وبدأت
أدرك أنني بحاجة إلى المساعدة لذلك  قررت أن أنظر
في الأمر ، قررت أن أكتشف ما هو
الخطأ معي ، وما الخطأ الذي أفعله ،
وما هي مشكلتي ، لذلك كنت أتوجه
إلى الإنترنت كما هو الحال مع أي شخص في مثل عمري
وبدأت في البحث عن الأعراض التي أعانيها ، ثم
اكتشفت الأمر  هذا الشيء المسمى
بالاكتئاب هو حالة نفسية
لأنني متأكد من أننا نعلم جميعًا أنه
يؤثر علينا بجعلنا نشعر بالحزن ،
فمن السهل جدًا الخلط بين
الاكتئاب والحزن لأنهما
يعنيان نفس الشيء ولكن الشعور بالحزن هو
عاطفة إنه  الشعور ويأتي مع
حدث شيء يجعلك حزينًا ، الدرجة السيئة
تجعلك حزينًا ، الشجار مع
صديقك يجعلك حزينًا ولكن الاكتئاب
أكثر من الاكتئاب هو الفراغ ،
إنه نقص في الشعور باليأس
واليأس أشعر وكأنه تشبيه جيد
لأن الاكتئاب محاصر في
قاع بئر وحرفياً لا توجد
طريقة حتى لا تتمكن من إخراج نفسك
من هذا المكان المظلم ، هذا ما
شعرت به اكتئابي لفترة طويلة جدًا ،
لذا بدأت في العمل عليه وعندما
وجدت  اكتشفت ما هو
الخطأ معي واكتشفت المشكلة التي كانت أنني
بدأت في العمل على حل
لذلك بدأت في التواصل وبدأت
أتحدث مع عائلتي مع أصدقائي
وبدأت في إخبارهم بأنني أعاني من هذه المشكلة
وإلى  مفاجأة لصدمتي ،
اكتشفت أنني لست وحدي
وفقًا لإحصاءات التعداد الأخيرة
حول 80 ٪ من السكان السعوديين
آسف أن حوالي 70 ٪ من السكان السعوديين
تقل أعمارهم عن 30 عامًا وحوالي 80
٪ من سكان المملكة العربية السعودية
قد عانوا  أعراض
الاكتئاب الإكلينيكي ، أنا سيئ حقًا في
الرياضيات ، لذا لن أحاول حتى تخمين
عدد الأشخاص الموجودين ولكني أعلم
أنه الكثير من الناس
ومشاعر اليأس واليأس
التي كنت أعاني منها.  يوم واحد جدًا
حوالي تسع مرات من أصل عشرة عندما
تحدثت إلى شخص ما عن الشعور
بالاكتئاب ، استجاباتهم أنا أيضًا
أعرف ما تتحدث
عنه شعرت أنني كنت هناك بسبب وصمة العار
التي لدينا مثل هذا  الرأي القائل
بأن هناك شيئًا مخجلًا في
Medora أنا أعرفه لأنني أعتقد أنه
يمكننا جميعًا الارتباط بهذا عندما أخبرت
الناس دون ذكر الأسماء التي
تعلمون أنني أعاني من الاكتئاب ، لقد سمعت
ردود فعل مثل نعم ، ظهرت هذه الملاريا
أكويلين أوه نعم  لا حرج
معك ، أنت بخير
ولكن الشيء هو أن الاكتئاب هو
حالة جسدية بالإضافة إلى حالة
ذهنية لأنه يضعفك
حقًا ويمنعك من عيش
حياتك ، فهو لا يعجبني أحيانًا
حتى أنني لم أستطع الخروج  من السرير
بسبب اكتئابي ، سأكون كما تعلم مستلقياً
على السرير في الساعة 8 صباحًا
لدي فصل يبدأ بعد
دقيقتين وأنا مستلقية هناك كما تعلمون
أنه لن يحدث اليوم لن
أقوم من السرير بأي حال من الأحوال ولكن ما أنا  لا
أفهم أنا  ساق مكسورة ، على سبيل المثال ،
سنحصل على جبيرة بشكل صحيح ، فأنت لا تصعد أبدًا
إلى شخص ما يمشي على عكازين
ويكون مثل مهلا ، هل يمكنني أن أكون ساقيك غير
مكسورة حقًا ، ربما كنت
تتخيل فقط أنها تنهض ، وستكون جيدًا.
لا أريد أن أنظر إلى الاكتئاب على
أنه حالة خطيرة وأجد
ذلك مؤسفًا للغاية لأنه
يمكن أن يكون له تأثير عميق على حياة الكثير من
الناس ، لكنني أعود إلى
نقطتي السابقة حيث ذكرت أنني
تمكنت من بدء طريقي إلى الشفاء  من خلال
التواصل مع الأشخاص من حولي
عندما بدأت في مساعدة أشخاص مثلي
عندما بدأت أدرك أن هناك
مشكلة تحتاج إلى إصلاح
وبدأت في تجميع أصدقائي معًا
، تمكنت من البدء في طريقي إلى الشفاء
، ذكرت أن الزوجين  منذ سنوات مضت ، كنت
قد وصلت إلى الحضيض الأكاديمي ، كنت
أعاني كثيرًا في المدرسة وكان
أدائي سيئًا للغاية ، ويسعدني جدًا
أن أشير إلى أن ذلك
لم يستمر طالما كنت قلقًا
من أنني  لو كنت قد أخبرتني
قبل عامين ، في أحد الأيام ، كنت
أقف على منصة TEDx للحديث
عن اكتئابي ، كنت سأضحك
بشدة لدرجة أنني كنت سأعالج
اكتئابي ، ومع ذلك حدث هذا قبل يومين ،
نعم ، نعم ، كان ذلك رائعًا قبل عامين.
لم أستطع حتى النهوض من الفراش للذهاب
إلى الفصل ، وها نحن ذاهبون للاكتئاب غير
قابل للشفاء بعد على الأقل وليس
بأي طريقة قانونية أعرفها إذا كنت
تعرف أي شيء قانوني يمكنني فعله لعلاج
اكتئابي ، تعال ورؤيتي  بعد الحديث
أريد أن أشير إلى
شيئين إذا كنت شخصًا
يعاني من أعراض الاكتئاب ،
أعدك أنه ليس دائمًا
شيئًا دائمًا تتحسن الأمور ، فهناك دائمًا
طريقة لتحسين الأمور لا يتعين
عليك العيش فيه  هذا المكان المظلم إلى الأبد
يمكنك الوصول إلى الأشخاص من حولك الذين
يحبونك ويهتمون بك ويريدون
رؤيتك تنجح في بناء نظام دعم
كن صادقًا مع عائلتك مع
أصدقائك مع أحبائك ، ابحث عن
شخص يمكنك الوثوق به وفتحه  فوق
لهم وإذا كنت أحد هؤلاء
الأشخاص إذا جاء إليك شخص تحبه
ويخبرك أنه يعاني
من شيء مثل الاكتئاب ، فلا يمكنك
التخلص منه جانباً ، يجب أن تكون قادرًا على
الانفتاح على هذا الجانب من حياتهم
يؤمن  بالنسبة لي ، لا يريدون جعل
حياتك صعبة ، من الصعب معرفة حياتهم
بالنسبة لشخص مصاب بالاكتئاب ، ولا يحتاجون
إلى الشعور بالذنب حيال جعل
أسرهم وأصدقائهم يشعرون بالسوء أيضًا ، ولكن في
مجموعتي الصغيرة من الأصدقاء
مجموعة من الأشخاص المكتئبين ، الشيء الأول
الذي نريد دائمًا أن يعرفه
الناس عنا هو أننا بحاجة إلى المساعدة
ولن نتواصل إذا
لم نرغب في الختام ببعض الكلمات التي قالها
أحد زملائي المتحدثين  أخبرني أن
ألهمني قبل أن أصعد على
المنصة ، السعادة المشتركة هي السعادة
مضاعفة والحزن
المشترك هو الحزن النصف لقد كنت
هانا حلوى اللحم ، شكرًا جزيلاً لكم على
الاستماع ، أتمنى لكم ليلة رائعة يا رفاق
[تصفيق]
[  موسيقى]